a vivir rodríguez es una enfermera que
atiende en primera línea de los
pacientes con kobe 19 y para trabajar
solo recibe un par de guantes y un
tapabocas al día ya se contagió de
coronavirus pero tuvo más suerte que
otros de sus colegas quienes pasaron a
engrosar la lista de fallecidos en
venezuela esto viene sucediendo hace
muchísimos años esto no es de ahorita
por la pandemia en el estado tiene
tiempo que que no surte a los hospitales
ni en cuanto a los métodos barrera ni a
medicinas diversas organizaciones
ligadas al sector sanitario denuncian
que el 95 por ciento de los trabajadores
de los hospitales públicos no cuentan
con todo el equipo de protección y
bioseguridad su fina cifra de sanitarios
muertos porcentualmente sería la más
alta del mundo pero los trabajadores
sanitarios como se le dicen al mundo
parecemos los astronautas totalmente
protegidas en el caso de nuestros
trabajadores no tienen la indumentaria
necesaria o se cumplen con las
exigencias que señala con mucha claridad
a la organización mundial de la salud
ante la imposibilidad del gobierno de
poder dotar los hospitales con material
de seguridad el gremio sindical
organizado a los trabajadores sanitarios
para que ellos mismos fabriquen sus
tapabocas cosen unos 300 al día para
repartir entre sus colegas es un acto de
apoyo pero también de frustración se
siente frustrante tener que sacar de
nuestro propio bolsillo para poder hacer
esto
cuando quien nos tiene que cuidar es el
propio gobierno
porque cuidar a un país no es solamente
hablar según cifra de la federación
venezolana médica el 30 por ciento de
los muertos por kobe 19 en el país son
trabajadores del sector salud en total
son más de 200 los sanitarios que han
fallecido y se estima que estos números
sigan creciendo mientras el gobierno
continúe sin garantizar los insumos
necesarios para trabajar
herminia fernández france24 caracas